[Music]
wow this is a world locked away to most
people under the roads and bustling foot
Pils of London hide Subterranean tunnels
and disused ghost stations when seven of
us went in there with torches it was
extremely I mean I'm getting chilled
just thinking of that experience of
seven of us walking through there with
torches a Jeep Chambers is a man on a
mission here he is with a film crew
underground in CL
exploring rooms undisturbed since the
50s we head that way just to see if it's
that they're leading the over the past 5
years he's dedicated himself to
researching and lobbying to open up
stations and transform them what I
really want to happen is uh they
become ultimate tourist attractions we
get to see touch feel the history of
being down there and all the people who
used to walk around down
there a Je estimat the disused stations
are worth1
billion transport for London the
government organization which manages
the city's tube Network say they can't
give a definitive figure but it's got
people's
attention AET says he's identified 26
sites some like these sitting on Prime
real estate let's say that it's not all
underneath as well because a lot of the
sites have air rights so developers are
very interested in building upwards um
in central areas of town uh some of
which look over Parks um and are
overcrowded as they are Transport for
London have told Bloomberg they have no
intention of selling stations but they
are considering if other parts of the
sites could be used so far on the left
hand side you can't see it just behind
the cupboard is um where we're hitting
Middle East investors at a jeet's house
in East Sussex he's planning out his
investor strategy he says ready to hit
go tfl give the all clear we have the
Consortium ready we've got the project
managers uh we've got the
investors a Jeet believes an
announcement is imminent possibly
starting a race to develop London
Subterranean
secrets